hallo herzlich willkommen zum krassesten
drecks video das ist hier auf einem
kanal gegeben bei uns wieder viel
aufwand gemacht für die zweite folge von
go die jetzt startet mit ausrüstung von
rechts holt eine geht's noch
natürlich kann ich nicht denn ich bin
ganz ausgewogen
wir haben unsere koordinaten bekommen
und sind mit dem auto bei einem baumarkt
angekommen wir sind wieder ins ländliche
gebiet gefahren also nichts was man in
der stadt benutzen kann
was ist ein wert wären wir jetzt
erfahren dass ein kranker netzwerk ein
wir wollten eine talent die krise geht
im baumarkt 50 euro und 30 minuten zeit
um alles zu besorgen was sie von einem
fluss braucht wer das jetzt erst
erreicht gewinnt diese folge will er
sich dafür angeboten hat uns die
aufgaben zu geben wusste ich schon das
ist zum einen sehr gut und auf der
anderen seite sehr schlecht sein wird
naja aber zum glück spielt das wetter
mit und wir können uns in diesem punkt
schon mal nicht beklagen also das wetter
es anders gar nur damit ihr check wie
viele es regnet es gab hier einen
erdrutsch 50 euro auch stabil dass wir
geist krank schwer auf der anderen seite
ich hatte keinen bock mehr auszugeben so
geil dass ihr uns die aufgaben stellt
wie die aber von unserem eigenen geld
bezahlen müssen
du kannst du länger ich darüber
nachdenke was für eine aufgabe bekommen
haben desto heftiger bin ich eigentlich
eigentlich freue ich mich extrem
betroffen ich glaube ich hab nix
komplett zerstört vergessen ist locker
frankreich oder
halbe stunde läuft viel besser als
gedacht ich habe diese einmal gefunden
das ist so perfekt ansonsten gibt es
wirklich wenige sachen die hier viel
auftrieb bewegen ganzen mitarbeiter
konnten überhaupt nicht weiterhelfe zwei
spanngurte mit schrauben oder bohren
muss
wir sind ready ich habe meine zwölf
einmal gekauft es sieht tatsächlich ein
bisschen aus wie die bauern variante im
gegensatz zu max setup mit styrodur und
man sollte sich nicht an rocket science
versuchen wenn man kein physiker ist
[Musik]
durch diesen verzweifelten jungen
mittlerweile bin ich so krank und dann
mag es komplett zerstört warte ab bis
wir auf dem wasser sind kleinere
schwierigkeiten sind das hier machst die
amerikanische ich die europäische
methode um eine fertige konstruktion ich
habe jetzt alles noch mal mit panzer
tape verstärkt habe hier die spannung
gute nochmal verschraubt hat mir
wirklich ein paar gedanken gemacht aber
das hier ist mal ein fertiges konzept
ich habe herausgefunden ist in 20 liter
eimern das bedeutet wir haben insgesamt
160 liter volumen in den eimern das
heute definitiv reichen um uns zu halten
weil ich wiege nicht ansatzweise 160
kilo mann sollte sich nicht an rocket
science versuchen wenn man kein physiker
ist das wird er starb sein mit dem wir
uns gleich den an schwung holen und dann
hoffen wir einfach dass wir nicht
untergehen dass wir stabil genug sind
jeweils einfach gedacht dass ich den
kompletten part wo ich das ding wirklich
bauer komplett raus lassen das gibt ja
keinen von euch deswegen bringen wir
direkt in die krasseste
challenge theben west in der wir mit
unseren selbstgebauten flößen
gegeneinander rennen gefahren sind und
was dabei passiert ist unglaublich es
war so schnell ihr könnt es euch nicht
vorstellen ich wünsche euch wir sind
halb nackt auf dem weg zu unserem flow
das hier ist echt strömungen drauf eine
an der oberfläche
man kann bei so einem fluss nicht
abschätzen wie viel power der wirklich
hat und dass hier sieht mir wirklich so
aus als ob die ja im leben das ist
anscheinend das setup der hölle ihr seht
mich auf 0,5 ich habe mein handy an
meinem arm befestigt platzierte alles
funktioniert hier ist mein klub max mit
seinem floß ich weiß nicht ob hier
irgendetwas hält mich ob mein gott ich
schwimme schöne und nutzt die hier ganz
entspannt in den sonnen und sturm
komplett abziehen und es jetzt komplett
genießen also man muss immer ganz kurz
sagen eigentlich hatten wir vorher
festgelegt dass es nicht erlaubt sei nur
eine panne unterstützung zu benutzen max
hat die regel nicht so ganz verstanden
oder ein bisschen überhört vielleicht ja
aber wie gut das funktioniert hat er
selber es funktioniert komplett max
schwindt halter per gesetz auf
[Musik]
das ist auch sehr unzufrieden stellen
ich muss mich einfach nicht treiben
lassen weil im gegensatz zu dir stimmt
man nicht los aber wie gesagt eine
einzige das stimmt ich glaube wenn mainz
die schmale ist man genau den gleichen
stelle war und auch überall roboter ist
ein großer nur wenn die hälfte der
käufer sind wirklich ein entspanntes
projekt mal keine flut draußen der hoch
genug ist also sozusagen dafür dass es
so wenig funktioniert hat war schon
extrem unterhaltsam und ich hatte den
spaß meines lebens
[Gelächter]
ich muss stuttgart einmal schön mir die
ganze zeit welchen kräften reihe klo
na ja das kam wie es kommen musste der
erste amtierende champion hat sich zum
sieg genutzt und mit den worten macht
und damit ist die zweite folge doch
beendet und geht zwar leider an max aber
das können wir in der nächsten folge
definitiv wieder rausholen es hat eine
menge spaß gemacht wir haben geile bloße
gebaut wir haben viel erlebt wie man
einen kompletten tag wieder interessant
naja freunde das leben ist funktioniert
eben nicht immer alles wie geplant dass
die messe dich das waren jetzt will ich
überhaupt kenne was jetzt mit geben das
video einfach nicht funktioniert ich war
mir ja abgefragt aber es war trotzdem
nicht vorenthalten
ich danke vielmals für den kraftsport in
den letzten tagen ist wirklich
geisteskrank sonntag kommt wieder ein
großes video und ein video das
hoffentlich funktioniert das was
vergessen
aber da sitzen würde das 100.000
abonnenten noch dieses jahr erweitert
abonniert jetzt diesen kanal wenn die
wir heute scenes kamen sehen wollt könnt
ihr gerne bei uns vorbeischauen wir
sehen uns am sonntag
[Musik]